vous êtes sur rtl
yves calvi 7h45 excédent de journée à
vous tous qui écouter rtl l aventure à
vous recevez donc ce matin le président
du sénat gérard larcher
bonjour gérard larcher bonjour cinq
jours après l attaque à la préfecture de
police de paris qui a fait quatre morts
parmi les policiers l'incompréhension et
la polémique ne retombe pas hier le
ministre de l'intérieur christophe
castaner a reconnu des failles tout en
indiquant qu'il n'y avait rien dans les
dossiers du tueur
est-ce que vous avez été convaincus vous
par les explications données par
christophe castaner on est d'abord sur
des faits gravissimes
ne l'oublions pas quatre policiers tués
et l'infiltration du service de
renseignement de la préfecture de police
de paris
alors on a les français ont le droit à
l'explication comment cela est il
possible et je dois dire que sur ce
poids qui a donné une information fausse
d'abord au ministre puisque je n'ose
imaginer qu'il n'est qu'en s'exprimant
jeudi en fin d'après midi pour dire
quelque chose d'erroné j'allais dire la
dig ce jeudi il dit et l'a blessé
différente vendredi même peut-être avant
pourquoi ne sert rien ne s'est passé
depuis 2015 par exemple quand on voit
les appliquons facebook de compte
facebook
l'attitude de ce policier pourquoi
continuer à habilité secret défense
alors que les choses paraissent assez
clair monsieur le président du sénat
vous demander la démission de christophe
quesson demande pas la démission des
ministres mais je crois que mon histoire
regarder ses responsabilités tous les
cas au sénat nous allons travailler avec
l'assemblée nationale travers de la
délégation parlementaire au
renseignement qui est sous secret
défense c'est à dire vous allez procéder
à des auditions secret défense de la
délégation il y aura des auditions de la
commission des lois qui commenceront
jeudi au ces en fonction des des
auditions
on verra quelle suite sera donnée mais
est-ce que vous allez demander l'attaqué
fonctionnement de l'état ce qui est sur
un sujet qu'on connaît la radicalisation
l'hyper radicalisation au coeur même du
service du renseignement
votre collègue de l'assemblée eric
woerth parle d'un scandale d'état me fit
des mots je dis que c'est à
dysfonctionnement majeur de l'état et
que ce dysfonctionnement majeur de
l'état nécessite de comprendre pourquoi
comment on compte faire les choses et
l'état doit regarder en face ses
responsabilités mais la parole du
ministre de l'intérieur
christophe castaner elle est affaiblie
ou pas je n'ai dire en forme de litotes
elle n'est pas renforcée qui peut le
croire aujourd'hui alors qu'il a dit une
chose jeudi en fin d'après midi que la
réalité était différente vendredi
sk ministre de l'intérieur ne doit pas
avoir un minimum de retenue avant
d'avoir tous les éléments
vous trouvez que le gouvernement agit
justement avec précipitation en tous les
cas le ministre de l'intérieur oui est
ce qu'un ministre de l'intérieur peut
dire je ne sais pas est-ce qu'il doit se
croire obligé de répondre je ne pense
qu'il ya une pression médiatique des
réseaux sociaux mais il faut mieux dire
la vérité que de commencer par l'erreur
je crois que au fond ce qui est touchée
regarder dans la sphère de rouen si
c'est qu'il n'y a plus aucune confiance
dans la parole des pouvoirs publics plus
aucune confiance dans l'état et que ça
c'est extrêmement grave
comment voulez vous qu'un état
fonctionne qu'une démocratie fonctionne
si plus personne n'a confiance dans ce
qui est incarné par le pouvoir exécutif
et parfois aussi par le parlement voilà
pourquoi c'est le devoir du parlement
d'engager ces contrôles et d'être en
exigence par rapport
au fonctionnement de l'exécutif gérard
lâché jean vient juste vous allez donc
lancé une série de d'audition
aujourd'hui même pour la délégation
parlementaire vous allez où l'un des
mots d'ordre qui nous est là le
président de la commission des affaires
étrangères de la défense et des forces
armées président de la commission des
lois appartiennent à la délégation
parlementaire au renseignement
jeudi ce sera à la commission des lois
et s'il le faut vous demander une
commission denquête ce sera la
conclusion de la commission des lois
sans doute en fin de semaine merci sur
la pma gérard larcher vous avez qu
environ 75000 personnes ont défilé hier
pour s'opposer à ce projet de pma pour
toutes les femmes
il y avait moins de monde un cas
l'occasion du débat sur le mariage
homosexuel c'est normal selon vous oui
d'abord parce que le débat av et -
hystériser qu'à l'époque de françois
hollande et de christiane taubira
moi je reconnais le droit à manifester a
exprimé sur un sujet qui est un sujet
important pour ne le concept de la
société
je pense que c'est au parlement que doit
avoir lieu le débat viendra au sénat au
mois de janvier
je souhaite un vous êtes plutôt
favorable à la main mais oui parce que
vous avez vos lignes rouges je suis pas
si céline roger à quatre conditions la
levée de l'anonymat
première des conditions l'interdiction
absolue de la gpa figurant dans le texte
ça doit être blanc un aliment de la gpa
la gratuité du don et ça dépasse seul
pema parce que ce texte est un texte de
bioéthique aussi et notamment le don
d'organes est considéré que la pma est
une possibilité
un confort de vie donnée ne relève pas
de la sécurité sociale de l'assurance
maladie
car il s'agit pas là ça doit être une
infertilité vont pas de remboursement
sécurité sociale gérard larcher le
président emmanuel macron a lancé jeudi
la concertation sur la réforme des
retraites en organisant un débat à rodez
dans l'aveyron vous croyez que la
réforme des retraites peut aboutir
écoutez en tous les cas on a déjà eu une
année et demie de consultation de jean
paul delevoye
nous mêmes nous avons organisé deux cols
au sénat nous voilà repartis pour nous
concerter sur la concertation et avoir
des débats sur les débats en fait c'est
parce que personne ne veut parler de la
réalité qu'est la question de l'âge et à
force de parler d' âge pivot de 62 ans
64 ans de durée de cotisations liées à
un moment il faudra dire la vérité aux
français
bien sûr en adaptant la réforme des
retraites un certain nombre de réalités
il ya des métiers pénibles
aujourd'hui il ya des professions
particulière mais quand j'entends le
ministre de l'intérieur s'est remis au
sénat veut dire que pour les policiers
on touchera rien dans une réponse à une
question d'actualité
je me dis qu'on va longtemps concertée
et qui n'est pas impossible que
l'horizon soit leur assure que les
débats avancent les régimes spéciaux
pour les uns et voulez vous oui c'est ça
va au delà c'est la construction d'un
système de retraite équilibré stable et
fiable dans le temps alors il n'y a pas
que le président de la république qui
fait des débats partout vous faites
votre tour de france vous aussi puisque
vous avez mené une dizaine de
conventions territoriales
qu'est ce que vous avez ressenti des
gens sont bien d'abord que le feu couve
d'abord pourquoi je fais ça c'est quand
même un vrai sujet pourquoi je me suis
mis à faire ça tout simplement parce que
je veux rassembler les familles de la
droite et du centre
déstabilisé depuis le printemps 2017 je
veux aussi voir ce qui se passe
réellement sur le terrain j'ai donc
donné aux conventions thématiques dont
le thème a été choisi par le terrain qui
n'a pas été les élus parlent aux élus
nous avons rencontré la société civile
des chefs d'entreprise des syndicalistes
et nous avons débattu au fond ce que je
ressens c'est que on ne supporte plus et
ce week-end dans la donne en exemple la
verticalité ce qui vient d'en haut
serait la vérité leuba n'a qu'à suivre
je pense que on s'applique une formule
en fait la confiance doit re re venir
d'en bas et je vois des raids
les réalisations des réussites
et parfois des problèmes assez
exceptionnel sur le terrain vous sentez
quads et des détentions je vous disais
est ce que le feu couve
est-ce que c'est quelqu'un je croisais
les conditions de 2008 n'ont pas disparu
et que les conditions de la crise n'ont
pas disparu j'étais samedi en haute
marne à la rencontre des maires et on
s'était un des départements les plus
gilet jaune
ils ont toujours le sentiment d'être en
dehors de la république ils ont toujours
le sentiment de ne pas compter et qu'au
fond leurs problèmes n'intéresse pas
grand monde et que par exemple quand le
ministère du budget décide de par
exemple supprimer les trésoreries sans
les consulter sur le territoire quand
vous avez des cantons qui sont énormes
ils ont vraiment le sentiment que ne
compte plus le président n'a kron a
échoué
tous les cas elle n'a pas encore réussi
ce qui est le rôle d'un chef de l'état
c'est la recoudre le pays gérard larcher
vous publiez un livre d'entretiens avec
la journaliste du figaro marion mourgue
qui s'appelle contre pouvoir qui sort le
9 octobre aux éditions d'observatoire
alors j'ai bien lu au tout début vous
écrivez je ne mens jamais alors êtes
vous candidat à l'élection
présidentielle de 2000 22 je ne suis pas
candidat à l'élection présidentielle de
2000 22 et vous aviez posé la question
parce que pourquoi vous écrivez si les
événements et les circonstances
politiques le décider j'assumerai
bien sûr c'est l'article 7 alinéa 4 de
la constitution c'est le rôle du
président du sénat d'assumer l'intérim
point à la ligne vous êtes deuxième je
le rappelle dans l'ordre de succession
lé troisième dans l'ordre protocolaire
vous n'y pensez même pas en vous rasant
non pas du tout mais vraiment la seule
chose auquel je pensais d'achever ma
tâche comme président du sénat mais est
ce que vous voyez quand même comme un
recours
ça vous pouvez le dire mais c'est pas
que je ne voudrais pas le dire je pense
que j'ai une responsabilité de
rassembler les familles de la droite et
du centre
j'ai la responsabilité d'être un
contre-pouvoir c'est pas moi c'est le
sénat parce que à chaque fois on tente
de personnaliser ses le sénat tout
entier qui est un contre-pouvoir
je crois que c'est indispensable dans
une démocratie d'avoir un contre-pouvoir
la capacité de dire oui et on l'a dit
sur 70 porteurs des textes et non quand
nous pensons que c'est pas l'intérêt du
pays
merci monsieur le président du sénat
gérard larcher merci à tous les deux un
entretien à retrouver comme